you know in Western Europe people tend
to think that colonies and imperialism
was about white people colonizing uh
colored people well actually in Eastern
Europe it was one white people
colonizing in other white people Ireland
is a good parallel to what to Russia's
role in Ukraine
and the the this war will stop when
President Putin and the Russian Elite
conclude that the Empire project is not
worth it
you know that going through the normal
but will they come to that conclusion
yes they will like you did like the
British did like the French think think
Algeria I think uh the French in
Indochina think Portugal in Angola and
Mozambique
um first you deny the your subjects
their otherness you know the British in
Ireland what are peasants having in
their own State what is this about they
just speak funny they speak our language
they're like us
um
then uh when there is violence you try
to put them down and then eventually if
you've suffered enough you say not worth
it let them go and it's only then that
you have a chance for us for a lasting
equilibrium the Russian opposition is
now having this important conversation
that the Empire project is bad for
Russia Russia is the largest state on
Earth doesn't need land it needs to
develop its people and its internal
resources and we need to help President
Putin and the Russian Elite to make that
judgment as soon as possible okay Mary
Beth
let me talk about the geopolitics of the
conflict so one could let me make a
distinction one could be very unhappy
about the current world order and maybe
some of the people sitting here are
unhappy and there are many reasons to be
unhappy for example within 10 years the
largest economy in the world will be
either China or the United States then
the third will be India the fourth will
be Japan and the fifth I think will be
Indonesia
well this new world is it reasonable to
think that the G7 with Italy on the
table
uh nothing against Italy but it will not
be in the top 20 countries in the world
uh is it reasonable to expect that the
G7 will decide the fate of the world no
we have to come up with a new world
order we all agree on that now it's
important to to think that even though
there will be a new world order there it
doesn't mean that the first proposal to
be put on the table will be accepted do
you agree with the Islamic States when
it puts forward the proposal for a new
world order a universal caliphate you
don't and when Putin puts on the table a
proposal which is essentially the return
to European colonialism of a different
kind we obviously cannot accept that and
part of the shock in Europe is that we
see the worst ghosts from the past radak
is right this is European colonialism
even you know think about the examples
of Braddock didn't give that Putin keeps
saying that Ukraine is a Russian
creation
to the most offensive insults you can
make to a people that probably is older
than the Russian people as a people
around it's the other way around here
that created Moscow it's the other way
around the forest and we and we need we
hear Echoes of the British saying that
Britain created India that India didn't
exist as a nation it was a a number of
principles uh but not a unified country
we're Echoes of how you know Portugal
create its colonies and so on and so
forth this is a
a colonial project the Imperial project
with
a genocidal element that we haven't
talked about but you know many colonial
projects have a genocidal element and
we've seen here
Putin doesn't talk about NATO Putin only
talked about nato in the couple of weeks
or a couple months before the war where
he was trying to Blackmail NATO once the
war started I have seen all his speeches
NATO never comes up what comes up is
interestingly the old Russian Colonial
past he told an audience of young
Russian entrepreneurs you know imagine a
an American president talking to young
entrepreneurs he would talk about you
know Silicon Valley technology the
digital future well Putin decided to
talk about how he is like Peter the
Great and Russia is now involved in a
project of gathering its lost lands
again this is the project for young
entrepreneurs if you're a young
entrepreneur you may want to gather some
lands so this is essentially Putin's
project a colonial project
I think in this in this competition
between China and and the West there is
more than a traditional geopolitical
competition because what you said
Kishore
similar Chinese civilization not
universalism what the West says is
universalism and our universalism it has
it it's Western it's it was born in
Europe then it became the West
it's about it has
spread around the world with the sword
with colonialism with imperialism so
it's a it has been it has brought the
idea of anti-colonialism with it it's
that's the complexity of this world and
now we are at the point where we realize
that we are no no we I mean than the
West we are no longer going to be the
center of the world and and the question
is to move from universalism to
pluralism which is a bit
to accept that they are in the balance
between the individual and the
collective that we've been discussing in
a way around this table uh for two hours
in this balance the the West has put at
the core of the individual and that has
been the core of its energy of its
dynamism this idea that the individual
has enormous agency we see in Asia that
the world I remember when I was working
for Banky Moon after Kofi Annan he used
the word harmony uh every every three
minutes uh Harmony the sense of the of
the collective and that's important
that's the community that's what dugin
also was mentioning and we have lost
that balance in the west and in China
this sense of community it can become
oppressive it can become the social
credit system it can crush the
individual and what we are looking for
is a balance which recognizes the agency
or the video so that history doesn't
stop so that there is movement so that
there is curiosity but at the same time
that this this focus on the individual
does not become
so strong that it becomes the war of all
against all this is where precisely why
it's very good we are having this
discussion
because there is a perception of China
among 12 of the world's population and
that is the perception of China in their
remaining 88 percent
and as you know if you look at the the
193 countries in the world I think 140
trade more with China than they do with
the United States as an example if you
look at 193 countries they have a free
choice as to whether or not to
participate the belt and Road initiative
130 countries have signed to sign it so
that it is no doubt that China will
emerge as a powerful assertive force in
the world I mean I don't don't you don't
have any Illusions and I believe that
the concept of a benevolent great power
is an oxymoron all great Powers will put
their own interests first and that's the
way we should uh react to it but the the
I can tell you the neighbors who are
working very hard to ensure that they
can work with this China and they and
they believe and this frankly I would
say if there's one lesson from East Asia
for Europe is that if you have a great
power in your neighborhood include the
great power in everything right and the
reason why we have launched the world's
largest Free Trade Agreement asean
launched it in January 2022 because
that's the way you anchor China